with a look at avoiding mistakes in the
college admissions and loan process an
options available to students seeking
financial aid this is about 50 minutes
thank you today's session on student
debt is sponsored by the National
Endowment for financial education and I
would like to introduce you to its CEO
and president Ted Beck Neffe has been a
supporter of Seibu for 8 years now and
we're very glad to have them as a
partner
Ted recently served as appointee to
President Obama's Advisory Council on
financial capability and prior to that
he was on the financial financial
literacy Council for President Bush Ted
also serves on the FDIC Advisory
Committee on economic inclusion and as
chairman of the JumpStart Coalition for
personal financial literacy we are very
proud to have him here with us today and
I'd like to introduce you to Ted Beck
thank you Joe for those of you that
don't know nephew were a nonprofit
organization that is solely focused on
improving the financial capability of
all Americans and we do that through
research and data gathering and one of
the things I think we're most proud of
is our relationship with Seibu we have
had this relationship for about eight
years now and we've been able to
actually sponsor this panel or its
equivalents in the last four sessions
because we provide a lot of data to your
membership and unbiased sources that
hopefully you can turn into great
stories we're also very pleased to be
holding this at the George Washington
University many of you probably know but
those of you who don't know actually one
of the top centers for financial
education in the country happens to be
located here it's the global center for
financial literacy
dr. Anna Luce Rd who is here in the red
is the head of the center and who is in
our book probably the top researcher an
academic expert on personal finance
issues in the country so if you call us
and we say gee we're going to get back
to you it's because we're taking the
time to call Anna and find out what the
real answers are so congratulations for
doing this here at the George Washington
University today's panel is something
we're very interested in the whole idea
of student debt has gotten great press
over the last
year just because of the magnitude of it
but we also think there's some very
critical underlying questions that
hopefully the panel will be able to get
at today issues like what is the
difficulty in finding jobs how are they
affecting graduating students the issue
of for-profit schools and how that's
eschewed the numbers and possibly the
biggest single issue that we're
concerned about is not the student who
graduates with $27,000 in debt but the
student who doesn't graduate and still
has the debt so some very very
significant media issues to talk about
and luckily you have an outstanding
panel here to do it and our moderator is
Kathy Kristof had well known to all of
you as an author a columnist and a past
president of Seibu so Kathy it's your
show so and I organized this panel
because I felt very strongly that we as
journalists and his parents were
involved in the conning of America's
children we told them that college is an
investment don't worry about going into
debt for this we told them that you can
go to any school you want we'll make it
work
we didn't tell them that your major is
gonna have a big impact on whether you
can repay your debt we didn't tell them
that there are differences types of
student debt and to be fair we didn't
know in a lot of cases a reason why we
con dar children is because the whole
student debt issue has changed so much
in the past 20 years that we as parents
had one experience and that experience
of our children is completely different
so I got together a panel of people who
can talk to you about really all aspects
of student that and how debt is
different one of the things I actually
I'm gonna stop because I was talking to
Becky Bisby who before this and she said
okay Kathy I said you know there's so
much to say and
and she said Kathy they're not here to
listen to you it's like okay we have a
program we know who all these people are
it's very impressive we want them to
talk and so I'm gonna make it very quick
I have Jane Bennet Clark from
Kiplinger's she not only is an expert on
student student loans on Colleges she's
also a parent and has had these
experiences herself
I've got Pauline Abernathy with takus
who is one of the world's greatest
expert actually both Pauline and Steven
Burt are the incredible experts on a
broad array of the differences in the
types of debt your repayment options and
also the incredible number of
legislative efforts that are being made
and consumer protection efforts that are
being made in the student debt arena
right now because the debt is truly
unique and actually among the most toxic
forms of debt we can get our kids into
so without further ado I'm going to
introduce you to Jane Bennett Clark
who's going to come on up here and just
so you know the program our speakers are
going to come up and I speak at the
podium for a few minutes and then we're
all going to sit down and hopefully
answer your questions okay Jane
thank you
so as Cathy says I have been covering
college financial aid we also have
annual rankings that we've been doing
for about a dozen years and so we've
been focusing on the value we focus on
net price and we focused on average debt
for for about a dozen years we also try
to explore the decision-making process
that parents go through as their kids
are applying for college and choosing a
college and I kind of concluded as both
a parent and as a financial reporter
that the admissions process as well as
the financial aid process really
encourages parents to make an emotional
decision about borrowing and here are
some of the reasons why first of all
families as Kathy mentioned put together
their college list based on academics
academic qualifications and oftentimes
they're they're kind of aspirational
lists it's like well maybe my kid can
get into this school they tend to sort
of focus on the reach schools and they
don't really focus on the the financial
aspect of it they start with the
academics and they put that list
together from that point of view and
then the colleges actually encourage
them to just wait to see what you get
especially when it comes to merit 8 and
then you can go on the college websites
and check out the net price calculators
but you're really not going to know what
kind of marinate your kid would get so
and I can tell you that I've done this
myself with I have three kids they're
all through college and so you get to
the point where your kids are getting
these letters and I have been in the
room when my own kid has been like
jumping around saying oh my gosh I got I
got into the school I can't believe it
I'm going to the school and I'm think to
myself
yeah and the other school was the one
that we could actually afford so now
it's like oh yeah I guess I guess we're
gonna send her to this school like yikes
so then you're just primed for the next
decision which is well how
a heck am I going to do this and what
happens is first of all the financial
aid letters sort of conveyed the idea
that they are doing you a big favor that
they're actually presenting you with
this financial aid award that is
actually largely loans basically
inviting you to take out a loan and I
can tell you that this is having to me
because my daughter
we got the financial aid award letter
and it it congratulated us telling us
that we we had the opportunity to take
out 100% loans to cover the cost we were
gonna get to take out a PLUS loan
and on top of whatever Stafford the
unsubsidized Stafford loans that we were
entitled to to begin with so that's a
very misleading situation and it's in a
very emotional situation I mean here you
are your kid has gotten into the school
of his or her dreams and you wanna you
you want to make that kid happy you're
excited so there you go and these loans
are easy to get I mean you can get a
Stafford loan pretty much with no no
underwriting nothing and PLUS loans you
know they have gotten a little harder to
get but basically pretty easy to get so
parents are ultimately signing up for
these things and the kids are too so you
know people have a responsibility to
think about it I mean you need to start
when you're putting the college lists
together and then you have to think
about it again you have to talk to your
kids and and say you know what can we
really do if we don't get the aid so I
think there is a level of responsibility
for the families too that you can't
blame it all on the college it's I think
families get set up for this but they do
play a role in this decision-making
process so
well go dick Pauline out or not thee and
my my plan with my children as I told
them really don't study that hard in
school if you get into a junior college
that'll be great
hey all you parents all you Tiger moms
you know you're gonna pay for that
sorry so thank you for inviting me to
speak here with the Institute for
college access and success teeka's we're
based in Oakland California have a small
office here in DC all of the things that
you just heard her are absolutely true
and one question I get often from many
of you is how could this be how could it
be though that the award letters don't
actually distinguish between loans and
grants how could it be that we expect
people to apply before they know how
much aid they'll be eligible for how
could it be that we don't explain the
difference between you know federal in a
private loan and the answer is when I
went to college when many of you went to
college it was an entirely different
world private loans barely exists
college did cost much less you could
actually put yourself through college
working during the year and on summers
the world has changed and college wasn't
as essential then as it was today for
everyone so we've got a dramatically
different world today and our policies
and practices have not changed we have
the same policies in place when fewer
people went to college college cost much
less the financial situation was very
different so we're in a process of major
ketchup of changing our policies and
practices to actually reflect the new
world so just a little bit of context
you all no doubt heard we have now more
than a trillion dollars of student loan
debt outstanding that's more than car
loans or credit card debt that includes
both federal and private loan debt
students are indeed borrowing more when
I went to college a majority of students
who graduated with a bachelor's degree
from a non-profit or public
did not borrow today two-thirds of them
borrow and they barrel an average of
$27,000 again that's federal and private
loan debt you hear a lot about students
who are borrowing $100,000 in graduating
from college with a hundred and thousand
those really are the outliers there's
less than 1% of undergraduates borrow
that much the average again is 27,000
1/3 aren't borrowing anything in student
loans but you do see more and more and
will be later this year there'll be new
federal data on federal loan borrowing
which will be a major development on but
the latest data we have is still for
many cases for 2007-2008 and what that
showed at that time was about 10% of
students were borrowing more than
40-thousand so and those students were
highly concentrated in the for-profit
college sector a majority of the
students who graduate from for-profit
colleges have both federal and private
loan debt and they have a much higher
level of debt than those in the
nonprofit or public sector what we say
often is it's not just how much you
borrow it's how you borrow and if you
complete to the point your ability to
repay as much greater if you have
completed school and what people don't
realize is their chance of borrowing and
completing varies dramatically based on
which school they go to it varies by
sector public nonprofit and for-profit
but even within those sectors there's
huge variations in terms of what the
cost actually will be what your
likelihood of borrowing anything your
likelihood of buying private loans and
your likelihood of completing and so we
need to be providing much better
information to families upfront so they
can make better decisions about where
they apply where they enroll right now
in fact some of the key data you would
expect in order to make those decisions
is simply not available it's not just
that it's available to two experts in a
you know hard to find place a lot of it
just simply is not available so what do
I
by that the federal government does not
collect the average debt at graduation
by college so we take us every year put
out an annual report on student debt for
the class of most recent one was 2011
will come out with 2012 later this year
we use a private data set that we buy
access to that school colleges
voluntarily participate in to come up
with that data and then put out state
data and school-based data but that data
should actually be required to be
reported and collected and made
available as a result because it's
voluntary the for-profit colleges
virtually none of them are participate
so essentially that is a study of
nonprofit and public colleges and only
those who choose to participate and each
year sometimes when we highlight those
that are high debt colleges they
disappear the next year they're not on
the list they don't report so that is
the basic data the administration has
put out a college scorecard that has on
it completion rates and debt information
which is a step forward to make to say
here's a one-pager that has some basic
information about this college but the
completion rates aren't for all students
but only for first-time full-time
college students which is a lot of
colleges particularly community colleges
for-profit colleges that's a very small
percentage of their students so it's not
a real graduation rate it can be very
deceptive likewise the debt data on that
scorecard is the median debt of those
who entered your payment so it's the
median debt of those who graduated and
those who dropped out and it also
doesn't tell you what percentage of the
students actually borrowed so again it's
not the information that most families
want and need to make good decisions
about where to apply but it is a huge
step forward I'm eluded now a couple
times to private loans versus federal
loans federal loans the terms are set by
the federal government they have fixed
interest rates they have a whole host of
consumer protections and an array of
flexible repayment
plans including income based repayment
which allows you to repay as a share of
your income so that your payments will
always be manageable and if after 20 or
25 years you have not repaid and full
the balance is forgiven
there is discharge of the debt if you
become disabled there's a host of
protections none of which are guaranteed
in the private loan is world private
loans are literally the riskiest way to
pay for college
it is like paying for college with a
credit card
they're usually variable uncapped rates
there's some fix now but they're
typically variable uncapped your very
little repayment protection or options
and they are not they're considered non
dischargeable in bankruptcy they're very
difficult to discharge in bankruptcy
unlike credit card debt or even gambling
that which are treated that is one of
the issues that we and a large coalition
and there's legislation pending and
Congress to change that treatment of
private loans to say they should be
treated just like other forms of
consumer debt not like alimony or
criminal fines so again it's not just
how much you borrow but whether you're
borrowing federal loans whether you're
borrowing private loans in terms of what
can be done so just very briefly and
then I'll turn over to Steve to leave
room for questions we have a whole
agenda to reduce the burden of student
debt on our website so I'll just talk
about a range a few key issues that can
be done to address this one is the
federal student loan policy so as many
of you know the interest rate on
subsidized federal loans is scheduled to
double again this July 1st from 3.4
percent today to 6.8% from our
perspective it makes no sense at a time
of record low interest rates to be
charging 6.8% on federal student loans
but that's exactly what will happen if
Congress does not act that they will
automatically double
there's an also the issue of the
doubling of them will make it more
likely that we'll see students turning
to private loans when they could have
borrowed a federal loan because they'll
say well this federal loan has a 6.8
percent interest rate this private loan
banks saying that starts as low as 2%
and won't appreciate the difference
between a variable rate and a fixed rate
and the different differences in the
types of loans and so we already see
even at the height of the private loan
market and no 708 1/2 of private loan
borrowers could have borrowed more in
federal loans so you can imagine what we
would see today if we suddenly saw all
the federal loans at 6.8% and private
loans being advertised aggressively as
low as meaning if you have perfect
record that will be your interest rate
today but it's going to go up each month
as interest rates rise and if your
interest if your credit record or your
parents credit record because private
loans require a cosigner if their credit
isn't perfect then it's not going to be
that low even today and it will only
rise over time so it's addressing the
federal student loans it's making sure
that borrowers know about income based
repayment
we've got peeping student loan default
rates in this economy and people many of
those borrowers could have avoided
default if they were aware of income
based repayment which only became
available in 2009 so we need to see a
lot more outreach to let people know
that England based repayment is there
and available to them we also need
better loan counseling upfront so that
when students making a decision about
how much to borrow they understand what
that's gonna mean to them in terms of
monthly payments and if they're in this
is their first year and they're gonna be
in school for four years that means four
times that amount
yeah and really helping them through
that the Department of Education to
their credit just did release a new loan
counseling tool with an online repayment
calculator it's long overdue it's a step
in the right direction of helping
borrowers make better informed decisions
and specifically during the counseling
that's required when they're leaving
school it allows borrowers to app as
part of the counseling pick a repayment
plan so they can literally see what
their monthly payment will be what their
total payments will be under each plan
and then pick one right there and apply
online so that's again an important way
of helping them pick the right plan for
them and get into it rather than
defaulting into a very expensive high
monthly payment plan which is the
current policy so I've already talked
about the need for better consumer
information we've got net price
calculators that help people get a sense
of what is the real price to them not
the sticker price which you know very
few people pay the sticker price so
every college now has a net price
calculator there's a college scorecard
we already talked about the
administration has put forward a model
award letter they're calling the
shopping sheet and more than 500
colleges that enroll more than 10
percent of students have agreed to use
them for the first time this year and it
will distinguish between loans and
grants it will actually make clear what
is the net price what is the price you
pay after grants that you have to either
earn save or borrow that is not the case
with most award letters today there's
bipartisan legislation pending in
Congress that would require all colleges
to use that kind of a standard award
letter so that families would have an
easier time comparing the offers it's
not easy even for someone like myself to
look at or letters currently and
actually determine which is a lower cost
College because of the way the
information is presented to other
private loans which I talked briefly
changing the bankruptcy treatment we
also need to be requiring that all
private loans be certified by the school
first to ensure that the student is
actually qualified for that private loan
and to ensure that the school can tell
the student hey you're taking out a
$5,000 private loan did you know you
could take out a $5,000 federal loan
that has these consumer protections some
schools do that voluntarily right now
but it's not required that
lender check with the school and it's
not required that the school tell the
student how much remaining federal loan
of availability they have and so that's
something that also there's legislation
pending it's something that the Consumer
Financial Protection Bureau could just
move forward to require as well which we
have been advocating for and equally
important for the millions of private
loan borrowers who have private loans
today many of them with interest rates
in the double digits and really they're
saying we hear from borrowers the
Consumer Financial Protection Bureau
hears from borrowers saying look I'm
willing to pay a hundred dollars a month
but they want $500 a month I don't even
make $500 a month and they can't get any
relief from their lender or any
flexibility the loans not dischargeable
in bankruptcy so one of the things that
is also pending next week is the
deadline for commenting on a request for
input from the Consumer Financial
Protection Bureau on suggestions for how
could we develop a way to make private
loan payments more affordable you know
what kind of a loan modification system
what other types of relief would help
address what they've seen in the
complaints they've received and then the
data they're showing where we've just
seen lots of people who are gonna not be
able to buy a home not participate fully
in the economy as long as they've got
that kind of unmanageable private loan
debt hanging on over their head and then
finally to end the last item that is
critical for keeping reducing the burden
of student debt is funding Pell grants
Pell grants are need-based granted it's
the largest core program that the
federal government has and even after
the recent increases in the maximum Pell
Grant it covers a smaller share of the
cost of a four-year public College than
it has since the program started it's
less than a third and it used to be well
over half well over two-thirds and you
know I can do and Qt I can talk a little
bit about why that is but we need to be
investing in Pell grants it is the key
to reducing the need to borrow
particularly for low-income students
he'll grant recipients are actually
twice as likely to borrow today as non
Pell Grant recipients and Pell Grant
recipients who graduate from a four-year
program nine out of ten of them have
student debt so they're much more likely
to borrow and in fact they also graduate
with $3,500 more debt than the average
non Pell grant recipient so we are
already expecting the lowest income to
take on more debt and that will only get
worse unless we are able to invest in
Pell grants going forward thank you
thank you pulling I want to actually
have you sit down up there and Jayne you
too because after Steve speaks we're
going to go to questions and I just
don't want to take extra time getting us
all situated
hello I hope everyone is doing well
James scared me a little bit because
I've got two little kids so I'm trying
to figure out how much debt that's gonna
be in about 15 years from now is very
frightening and if I have to tell them
I'm already telling them that Montgomery
College I live in Montgomery County and
Maryland is the way to go so my name is
Steve bird with the New America
Foundation we're a public policy think
tank in Washington before coming to New
America I was a reporter at The
Chronicle of Higher Education for 15
years I started covering student loans
in 1995 and the changes that have
occurred over that period of time are
just amazing
at that point very few people very few
undergraduates were taking out private
student loans in fact I never thought
about covering them at that point
because you just didn't hear about them
so it was a surprise even to me when you
know about ten years later you started
started hearing these horror stories
about undergraduates with these loans
and how aggressively lenders were
marketing them so I wanted to talk a
little bit from the students perspective
on this but I just wanted to start off
by saying the federal government has
subsidized loans to college students for
nearly 50 years when the government's
main loan program the Stafford loan
program first began it was intended
mainly for middle-income students to
help them to afford to go to the College
of their choice as late as the early
1990s less than half of all bachelor
degree recipients were taking out
student loans today two thirds do and as
Pauline said that with an average debt
of about $27,000 per borrower overall
students and parents borrow an estimated
a hundred and twelve billion dollars a
year through the various federal loan
programs in addition students have our
nearly 10 10 billion dollars a year in
risky private loans
which as Pauline said are almost always
more expensive and less consumer
friendly than federal loans student
loans have long been considered a good
investment providing individuals with
the means to obtain an education that
would pay dividends you know pay
substantial dividends throughout their
lifetimes but it's been increasingly
clear that many students are finding
themselves with unmanageable levels of
debt that could hamper their future life
choices such as getting married buying a
house having children and retiring if
you want to get a sense of the
significant toll that the our student
loan policies have had you just have to
look at some of the comments that
financially distressed borrowers have
submitted to the Consumer Financial
Protection Bureau recently I was looking
at their site the other day and I came
upon one borrower who has a very
substantial debt load rope
even with the income I generate from
working two jobs and my wife working one
job
we cannot afford many things because the
amount we must page month to the student
loan companies we cannot afford health
coverage which in turn limits our
ability to start a family as we both
will turn 30 this year we feel that time
is running out for us to be able to
reach our personal goals and dreams
another borrower who pays over $1,600 a
month on his federal and private loans
wrote I will never own a home because of
this crippling debt I have faced since I
graduated college I can't even buy a car
because I can't qualify for a car loan I
Drive a 2000 Honda Civic that will die
on me someday and I have no idea what I
will do to these borrowers make mistakes
certainly and they readily admit it but
what kind of system requires teenagers
at the ripe age of 18 to make financial
decisions that could have such a
life-altering effect on such a
life-altering affect as another borrower
wrote coming out of high school I didn't
realize that taking on this much debt
could affect me this much financially I
just wanted to get get away from home
and get an education students in the fit
and their families are generally left on
their own to navigate a complex do
system offers a variety of choices each
with different interest rates and loan
limits yes the education department
requires colleges to provide entrance
counseling to students but it often
comes too late in the process after
borrowers have already committed to
taking out the loans by signing their
promissory notes and it's often
perfunctory the first weeks of college
can be overwhelming and the last thing
that many students want to do is focus
on the details of their student aid
packages federal student loan borrowers
also face a baffling array of repayment
options the government offers
financially distressed borrowers various
ways to stay out of default such as
forbearance deferments and income based
repayment but these choices all have
their own rules and regulations and
require borrowers to actively take steps
to enroll and stay in them unfortunately
many borrowers simply don't receive the
kind of counseling they need to
understand the choices that are
available to them or what they need to
do to take advantage of them once
students leave college they're truly on
their own to sort these things out as a
result many borrowers unnecessarily fall
behind on their payments and end up
defaulting the consequences of
defaulting are severe ranging from
ballooning repayments to ruin credit
ratings and the loss of professional
licenses federal policymakers have been
it much more difficult for bars to
discharge their student loans in
bankruptcy than any other form of
consumer debt and have removed any
statute of limitation on the collections
of these loans allowing the government
to literally unleash an army of student
loan collection agencies who can pursue
the falters to the grave
they have also empowered the government
to garnish say the wages of defaulters
without a court order and cease tax
refunds and other federal benefits such
as portions of Social Security payments
from elderly and disabled borrowers it's
certainly unacceptable for students to
take out federal loans without having
any intention of paying them back the
reality however is that many if not most
people who default over loans do so
because they simply can't don't have the
money to repay them they are not looking
for a free ride
yet our system for student loan
collection does not recognize this
crucial distinction borrowers who
deliberately skip out on their loans and
those who are too financially distressed
to repay them are subject to the same
harsh treatment many lives are ruined as
a result so what can we what can we do
to what are some of the steps that we
could take Pauline teeka's is really has
some really great ideas and I would
definitely recommend that you you go to
their website one of the one of the
areas that they are really that some
some ideas about a better loan
counseling they have really impressed me
and I would definitely suggest that I we
believe that the new america foundation
that there should be a single loan
program for undergraduates with the same
terms and conditions for all borrowers
and that income based repayment should
be the default repayment option for
students meaning that students would
automatically be enrolled in the program
which would allow them to pay back their
loans as a percentage of their income
after they graduate such a system would
recognize that some people just simply
don't earn enough to fully repay their
loans no matter no matter how earnestly
they try to as I said loan counseling
needs to be strengthened and Congress
needs to make private loans
dischargeable in bankruptcy like all
other forms of consumer debt only then
while private loan providers have any
incentive to work with financially
distressed borrowers to ease their
burdens through loan modifications and
refinancing options that are generally
not available today I'm gonna stop there
and I look forward to your questions
thanks Steven and before we go to
Question and Answer I just have a couple
questions for the audience how many
people are here because you have
children who have debt and you really
just want personal okay right how many
people here are looking for a way to
cover you know student loans you know
college all that stuff great I want to
throw a couple of ideas at you because
there are so many things that I think
could help us raise the
and bar in how we cover college one of
them is every one of you have local
colleges in your neighborhood and you
can find out just exactly how good they
are at graduating kids in less than six
years which has a huge impact on how
much you pay for college how much debt
the kids come out with at the end of the
school and whether they graduate kids at
all some of the private colleges if you
go to the College Navigator site it's
the valence college navigator org dot
gum sorry if you go to the College
Navigator site all this data is there
and it's on mind and if you want to do a
comparison of all the colleges in your
little area I think it would be the most
incredibly mind-blowing thing to your
parents readers because you would
suddenly see oh look at this college
that my can son wants to go to that is
charging forty thousand dollars a year
they graduate ten percent of their
students if you are one of the 90
percent who don't graduate and you
borrowed for that education your chance
of being financially devastated for the
rest of your life is huge you also there
are step-by-step tutorials that I think
we could do much better job of doing
just on you know what do you do when you
graduate you know five tips for you know
paying off your student loans um but
again I think it's some of it is just
all in your in your local neighborhoods
look at your individual colleges go in
and compare like what the administrators
are making versus what they're charging
College compare how much they give to
needy students compare their award
letters do I mean hold their feet to the
fire because in fact we've been too easy
on schools we've we've acted as if they
were giving our kids something so
valuable and actually we've acted like
they're a commodity we don't do a great
job of comparing one school to the next
and the differences between schools are
actually life-altering so with that I'm
going to and go to
does yes come on up to the microphone hi
I'm Karen Miller I'm a Seibu member from
Reading Pennsylvania writing mEagle my
question is why do you think colleges
don't make a greater effort to reduce
their price has anyone tried to itemize
exactly what goes into the cost of
college and year and why wouldn't they
want to make their product more
affordable do you guys I'm going to say
they don't have to but go ahead there's
a microphone right now so if you look at
their - I have two different answers to
that one is called the shibboleths regal
effect which mainly mainly affects
private colleges I would say but also
some of the sub publics where basically
it just lowering prices makes you look
bad in the market you don't want to look
like you're just you know you're a
discount that you're discounting your
the education that you provide so
colleges there's a great pressure to
keep up with the competition and to
continually look more expensive which is
just strange but then the other aspect
for public colleges is a lot of schools
don't really have a choice because or
they have choices but the states have
just been cutting the amount of money
that they provide these schools and so
the easiest way to deal with these cuts
is to raise prices well I do think that
there is an issue with you know there
was kind of a backwards way of
approaching it because colleges have -
they do have to give out a lot of
financial aid and oftentimes marinate or
tuition discounts in order to fill the
seats but then that means that they have
to raise tuition to cover the people
that aren't getting that then aid it's
just like that's kind of a vicious cycle
in that sure
many people don't pay the sticker price
but somebody's got to pay the higher
price and and this whole issue of
enrollment management is such that
colleges work very hard to figure out
exactly how much you will be willing to
pay to come to their college and they
will give you just enough to get you in
the door but not necessarily as much as
you can afford to pay so it's just like
this very kind of situational such a
type of financial model that I think of
them as auto dealers you know you walk
into the showroom they size you up well
how much will this person pay for the
Mercedes that is what they're doing to
be with college they really are and if
you go in and your kid is so set on
Georgetown not that I'm speaking from
experience you're just gonna find a way
to let them go to Georgetown and that's
the thing if they figure they don't have
to give you aid to get you in then they
won't give you aid to get you in the
other thing too is we when you are
telling your kids to have apply to all
the reach colleges the top of the list
is less likely to give them any sort of
aid it's the colleges that they totally
fit into their profile that are more
likely to get them aid and if they go to
a college that is a little under their
you know their status in for grades and
SAT scores those colleges are gonna give
them a lot of age where do we tell them
to go top of the list right so we're
part of the problem no the car dealer
analogy is actually I think a very good
one in that for more than 50 years we've
had those sticker sheets and the window
sheets that have been required by
federal law on cars we we're only now
debating doing that for colleges with
these standardized award letters but
that's how far behind we are but it's
exactly the same idea of allowing
helping consumers make an informed
decision
really want to underscore you know
Steve's point that that what's driving
the cost and why you don't see a lot of
reductions in price although we're
seeing more in the last few years you're
seeing many more psychologists saying
they're freezing tuition they're
lowering their tuition but the key it
really varies by sector for-profit
colleges set their prices very
differently than public colleges which
are primarily different driven by their
appropriations and the withdrawal of
state appropriations nonprofit colleges
yet again a different factor and
depending on their level of selectivity
different factors go into account and
how they set their prices but also want
to underscore the point that you know
everyone needs to be looking at net
price not sticker price that the college
with the highest sticker price will
often be the most affordable
particularly for low-income students you
know they're gonna go to Harvard if they
can get into Harvard they're gonna go
for free they're gonna get dramatical
college it might be public or nonprofit
have a much lower sticker price so we
need to get people help readers
understand that it is net price not
sticker price you need to look beyond in
there now are some tools to help people
do that hi I'm Colin Campbell I'm a
student as it were at the University of
South Carolina and we've written about
this with the student newspaper the
daily game talk a good deal and one of
the one of the things we've read about
obviously that the doubling of the the
student student loans federal loans has
come up a couple of different times and
keeps getting you know pushed down the
road and one of the things that that we
noticed we were you know obviously you
want to try to source and get people who
are on both sides of that argument and
people who are proponents of you know
that that thing doubling their argument
is what we need you know how else are we
going to put our foot down on the
colleges and and you know if you make
that loan rate double then colleges are
gonna have to bring down their prices
you know it's gonna it's gonna really
you know put their feet to the fire like
you were talking about it you know if it
stays low which I mean I think I agree
that it needs to but if it stays low how
else do you keep their feet to the fire
fire what what else can you do
to force them to do that I think the
interest rate it doesn't actually do
that for our colleges yeah
eighty percent of the students who take
out subsidized loans that have the three
point four percent interest rate have
unsubsidized loans as well so they're
already paying six point eight percent
on their loans so they're already taking
out both three point four and six point
eight percent rate so it's not stopped
had the impact I think the only people
who benefit from student loan rates
doubling are the private lenders hi amy
Zipkin saber member freelance journalist
I was wondering if any on the panel
could address the FAFSA and the parents
obligation and the FAFSA because when we
did it and we did it in the spring of
eight which was very different than the
fall of eight we came up with a very
different number and the schools were
recalcitrant and their negotiating
ability on this number and you know we
kept on scratching our heads because it
was based on really parents income I
mean the student if the student had you
know a thousand or two thousand dollars
worth of savings from a part-time
after-school job
it seemed that the schools were
expecting the families to go out on a
limb based on an income level that would
never be the students the FAFSA forms
have changed actually dramatically since
2008 and they're a little bit easier to
negotiate right now but one of the
things that you should do is get Cal
Cheney's book paying for college without
going broke because it actually takes
you step-by-step through the FAFSA form
and there are a lot of mistakes that
parents make on that form because normal
English is not how it's written and so
if you read it and are in particularly
if you skim through it because it's like
you know massive and you don't want to
read all 300 pages or the instructions
you are likely to make some very costly
errors and that book will lead you
through how to do that without making
those costly errors but it actually is a
little bit easier than it used to be
we're being told that we need to wrap up
so I'm going to just have you guys go as
fast as you can and we're gonna try and
answer as quickly as we can until they
kick us out hi my name is Oliver st.
John I'm a small business reporter for
USA Today I graduated from college last
year and out of like almost all my
friends I was the only one I'm like the
only one who's not working it like I
don't know bruger's bagels or something
and a lot of the like a lot a lot of my
friends are wondering like god like was
this was this worth it I don't know if
when I made this decision if this was
something I should have done when I was
like 17 or 18 and this I mean not not to
say that like my parents should have
made it for me that would probably been
even worse but maybe I should have taken
some time off like done something else
like nope nobody really know is like are
there are other options to I don't know
help you help you make that decision
better or do you have to make it when
you're 17 years old these are one of the
things that I think would be so great if
we helped counsel parents in the
newspaper and you know on TV if we gave
them a little bit of emotional support
for it saying to your kids
seriously junior college is not such a
bad option you know take taking two
years getting your undergrad done
someplace where you're not going to have
any debt not a bad option that in my
community there's a lot of Mormon
families their kids go on it too your
mission and they come back so much more
mature and ready to go to college and
instead of failing their freshman year
they actually whoop study okay and if
that's then they don't have to take all
classes or I mean I can't the number of
kids who take five and six years to get
through college
is phenomenal and some of that is
I think the maturity of the student that
you know how prepared they are really
for college and but as parents and as
journalists we don't we don't present
that this is a really good option for
kids you know don't just go down this
path because all of the parents in your
neighborhood are talking about Harvard
and talking about Princeton and talking
about all these places don't be pushing
your kid to go to something that you
know as a parent they're not you know
ready for but I would just add to that
that the research is really clear the
data is very clear the unemployment rate
for those who don't go to college is
more than twice as high as those who
have a college degree so on average is a
much better invite it is a good
investment but people need to be much
look much clearer about where they go to
college do they you know go and take six
years or can they get it done faster
because that's gonna have significantly
less debt and what are they studying and
to think about those things more
carefully I'd also like to add that one
of the things that you want to think
about in terms of whether it's worth it
is how much did you borrow to to get the
degree and I mean if you bard maybe ten
thousand five thousand maybe it is worth
it at the end of the day but if he
borrowed forty or fifty thousand dollars
and I would say yeah probably not worth
it in some schools particularly in
community colleges there there are
students who probably would be better
off if they were taking out a loan than
trying to work two jobs while going to
school because their chances of
completing are so low if they try to do
it without borrowing anything at all and
if they took out that one loan to help
repair their cars so they could get to
the campus they'd have a better chance
of completing and that would be a good
investment
Warren is telling me that he's gonna
send in the saber bouncers if we don't
get off this stage but I'd like to
suggest these guys will stick around for
a little while and can answer questions
one-on-one they're incredible resources
so if you cover this topic or if you
want to cover this topic and come up get
their contact information thank you very
much